you know Theo does his podcast out here
I saw the other
yeah the bees people with a big
background no green screen that's the
wood back there oh yeah it's just it's
like between two ferns or something you
know like some sort of talk to chats in
the garden were so full podcast what's a
full podcast man with my co-host right
here Johnny rookie yeah yeah he's right
here
Lisa's here to my three gold is in
Mexico getting married getting fatter
know the secret he's getting married man
you just didn't want to invite no one do
it cheap as hell you didn't bat bro this
morning he ate like a big bowl up of
solid dude like I said I was like yeah
there was a big-time woman there in
Mexico she was making this big part but
it was boil it was sizzling it was our
beef with harmony and the a seal and
rose and homemade corn tortillas but
with the bone still in it is psychotic
us and then forgotten one of those those
are those things who take of a zip line
for food we have Lidia Popovich right
here hey nobody people will come in
later but we gonna just jump in whenever
she can alright alright live we're gonna
ask you a questions about what was it
like coming up as a comedian in the Bay
Area okay wait a minute
as the punchline brew they make you hang
out for a year before they give you a
set of [ __ ] is that dog talk just
shaking hands
I remember Marilyn somebody's time yet
to do that I was like no way man you
buddy looks like a communist or at least
we're if you hate
for six months somebody's gonna go hey
man you want to go up yeah throw in the
belly room or something I think that
only works if you are a man because I
have been here for two years and no one
has ever like tapped me on the shoulder
at The Comedy Store but like hey man
you've been around you want to go up
that hasn't happened to you
Skyler stolen what's up there books like
people with a lot of TV credits on his
shows
it's Skyler and Sam Triple E they do
they book those comedy regulars at the
Comedy Store in their book what do they
charge you get it what's your favorite
room at the Comedy Store the back way
[Laughter]
you could be there smoking a fat ass
backward bro falooda 13 and you want you
just you see Bob Saget lucky enough to
having a best head we're not bad Stan
you know but you know it totally yeah
look at that level man it's a little
late Bobby but just know deep down
inside man little bit when you go back
to the old [ __ ] bro I always think
that's nice that when you see someone
that's been doing it forever and you
have like you catch them in that one
pensive moment where they are thinking
about I don't know and then I'm like
okay it's never gonna go away
it's never gonna go away it's always
judging yourself off your path sighing
constantly oh also also like that that
that little VIP private bar they got now
yeah the little video room bar I like
that place a video room was down there
like around the corner like through the
kitchen on the left yes yes that's new
yeah it says video room on the door I
don't know I don't know I've never
actually watched a video in there at all
but the closest to a video is just Jimmy
Schubert doing like a little magic
tricks which is kind of like watching TV
go watches live live on youtube.com
80c so I know you got the right watching
us right now one Instagram we got an 88
88 subscribers I
so people will leave this on for now do
we get the YouTube channel okay okay
we're back
I've been to that room once what's it
named while with George Perez ah the the
new the secret green room
okay people we're gonna go sideways it's
a it's a cool little room though because
it's just nice because a lot of people
don't know it's there and they walk
right past or they just assume they
shouldn't be in there and most people
shouldn't but it's a chill quiet place
when you are in the Comedy Store and
there's people everywhere
I do love going in there and the
bartender's in there are sweethearts so
you can go in there and get a little
drink and hang out put your feet up
enjoy yourself it's good that's why they
call it the know what the video room I'm
going to back yeah I don't know there's
lots of signs in the company store that
don't say anything that they don't mean
I was replaced in the comedy store where
when I had to get when I could party but
before they did all the other before the
changes started yeah a nice to wander
off man and and go up to here
because I'm I read that book that book
on that's based on the show on Showtime
but I'm dying I'm dying every I read the
book and there's there's not when they
were on strike
Mitsy had little places where she could
watch to see who that what comedians on
strikes when she could ban them so there
was like secret little passages or toys
you could look at them that place is
like the Winchester Mystery House though
for real like there are so many doors
that open into stairways that open into
other places like when you think you
have seen everything that the comedy
store has to offer there is definitely a
dark alley you have never walked down
like I heard that's what they're doing
now they have like streaming on there
now let's go her to that's like their
new hot [ __ ] is come sit in the basement
have you been to the belly room but the
next room next to the belly room the one
behind the behind the room yeah yeah and
then there's stairs that those these
would be stairs I'll take you down and
around yeah those are clear kitchen yeah
those are still down that come come back
around again
I think that little passage that little
area was made for for Mickey Cohen the
mobster yes because for our celebrities
or in any high-class people could slide
in their side chicks with all the white
noise Wow your wife's in the room yes
let the ultimate club man where the club
is set up so just in case drama starts
you left yeah but that's I was a waiter
at la factory when somebody's wife came
in and his side-chick was upstairs and
she was ushered about and down the back
stairs and then waited out in the alley
and then he was doing that you know and
it's wife how disrespectful whatever and
then I'm like what's wrong with that
girl she's willing to wait out there in
the alley that's what you do that's
howling is an art appreciate hos enough
is an art like its motion like her cuz
you don't you don't just wake up and say
I'm gonna be a [ __ ] choices over and
over escalate higher and higher and you
get deeper into that whole life and you
shake it out it's like oh now he's
wanted to have a baby
sure doubt to the side
she was ushered out to the back alleyway
and she waited yeah I guess she left
eventually he must have said goodbye to
her because his wife stayed the rest of
the night well you know you gotta give a
[ __ ] cab fare you know yeah I mean
you're gonna make sure she gets home
saying otherwise she's gonna call
someone else cuz that's the thing - is
it like side chicks are usually multiple
sexual ok yeah so if you got to make
sure that your ho is attended to
otherwise she's gonna call someone else
and then you're knocked down on that
list being a side feels like a marathon
stick around
what got you out of the side peace
business what were you out Johnny like
what
you tired you find out I did I went over
the right way in high school and college
that doesn't even count looking for a
commitment no not at all I was like
we're friends
a friend then you you just so happen see
I don't think it counts high school and
college doesn't count that's just that's
called living your life you gotta be
like thirty four forty one of you has to
be married or you have to have been in a
relationship that's like very very very
long time and though some of those long
terms yours have to be over 18
like you can't I'm sorry but any latter
it's impossible to be like a man when it
is 50 to be somebody side beat man she
will be drew Barrymore for my 50 dates I
do like the idea though of like a 50
year old man there's just like living
that side playful would have to be
healthy at five dogs right it's tiring
take his vitamins a lot of ginger a lot
of ginseng you know maybe does yoga
you'll avoid them I got two hours let's
try to make a big deal you got time you
got I want to do this longer but I
didn't know I want time over the side
people before I believe sorry for men I
was living on them be and I was seeing
this woman for a while you know we never
like I never went to her house I never
actually went to her house ever and we
will meet somewhere and then go to my
house okay but I never noticed these
things right and then one day I'm still
wearing a show and her friend tells me
you know she's married right and I said
no I didn't know how'd you feel I think
you were following up with this dog like
perfect she's not
continuously I confront to her and I
saying I found out you know you're
married at the whole time
that's pretty slick crying it's like
heroin I'm fascinated by you Jenny
because like you're a very serious
person but then there's like you throw
these little gems of like oh I don't do
that anymore like oh yeah that's like
you've hearing like I'm just like damn
what were you like like no to Mordecai
[Laughter]
[Music]
absolutely I was a leader shows for
American insurance and they were doing
some other events some other convention
they told me they assured out a big ask
actor through the back row because I'm
he was they were his side-chick
and the wife showed up for the wife
friend was there yeah like big bro
oscar-winning actor and the wife start
the West our dominance right yeah the
fool would it I would in Austria for
movies and cheating room would you
involve third party corporations help
you like that is yeah man you got to be
careful because like as you get bigger
and bigger like it's harder to harder to
cheat right like you that's why you have
to have like NDA's and you have to like
buy an apartment for our lady or like
exactly these ought to keep him
sequestered because think about like you
would your money like you don't just
like write checks all willy-nilly you
have a financial planner you may ask
plants if you're gonna cheat do some
preparations those are guy that that
little guy right somebody wants to do
that man i buy houses clothes just for
joy yeah yeah that's okay
like double wives and like they get
wholesomer family oh yeah that's some
wild [ __ ] to having can you imagine how
many like a whole other family like a
secret me I have actually multiple
friends that like found out later in
life that their dad's had whole other
families well it was to be airline pilot
huh like well military a lot of military
salesman's consultants and stuff like
that but that I mean that's that takes a
lot talked about long lifetime
preparation Pablo Escobar did it the
best in like that show narcos my head
his sidepiece was like the news lady and
then she started talking trash about
wife and hoes to like of three the one
where they're doing them in the Cali
cartel I think that three season three
that C 3 that guy has two wives and
they're ok with it like I hope he was
one wife on Monday Tuesday Wednesday and
Tuesday and the other one on Wednesday
and Thursday and then he'll go on
they're going on Friday and instead and
then Sunday he was both within my church
and activities now let me ask you this
you guys are both men obviously you're
both men that enjoy ladies you're a
married man you have been a side piece
before I don't know what your stable
looks like now I'm assuming that it's
been spared down by a little boy but
like that seems like a lot of work like
I understand like the variety of ladies
but like what's the appeal they're like
would you really want it like would you
want to have two wives and I don't know
if that's a trap question but like that
just seems crazy to me I was like a lot
of work not two wives that's right
that's soon to come in but like a wife
and a side piece like that's better but
like two committed wives I feel like
it's a lot girl it's a lot of work you
like to marry no one is enough more than
one woman is more than I guess
yeah confusing and a little bit before I
have and it's not it's it's not all that
it's cracked up to be
well you see really stupid with one no I
was serious with any of them that's why
it worked because it was like three of
them and I was trying to figure out I
was just an emotive like let me just
date some people and have non but just
dated yeah that's not a relationship
yeah but it's still that was too much
for that and I was like I don't even
like the eyes and I can't even keep this
stuff together I'm just like trying to
figure out if I liked any of them good
enough to like keep I did only have one
day day moving in my house after other
time there was no Netflix there was no
newbie Bros it was just like browse man
I should take an old-school Lydia and I
took when I slowed up I took one of the
road about I remember was on the road
and I were the person I'm a with rented
a [ __ ] DVD player or a VCR from
Blockbuster be good a condo they have we
did it right now oh my Lisa like we went
to do the whole DVD player and up in a
game console yeah Wow God they do their
severs are holy years ago lose their
mind there's no people we used to walk
around this video store just looking at
videos yeah the way we wander around on
their play for hours yes
I'm a ghost or memorize completely
memorize and then Lisa I will go to the
video store there was more more of
hipsterish
2020 video yeah enough we had a lot of
independent movies and then here lately
um what is that o criterion movie my
Syrian collection yeah
important thing you're supposed to see
every movie bro every single movie if
you didn't have it I'll get it for you
right movie with that guy he comes out
on that one TV show and then he's like
kidnaps that one woman and then the guy
looking for a movie with a guy I think
it's Christopher Walken and that guy who
came by the mercury who played JD John
for Robert foresight and I don't know
there's the thing that keeps saying in a
movie or any Garcias Danny and they say
hey man you're gonna get buckwheat I'm
gonna shoot you in the ass
oh yeah bro that thing to do it there
but you're dead starting Christopher
Lloyd I'm waking more than 2000 when
during 9/11 so I pretty much disappear
boarding pretty good movie yeah they
used to give their opinions right yeah
the guy does the only review you have
their lives like lately like um like a
pause list
yeah oh geez I remember making fun of
kids cuz they'd have to rent their
console and I only were you one of those
little kids brother if your mother took
you anywhere you had your little
favorite movie with you all the time
no I don't know TV with me and all the
time that's crazy
my son ran he did carry it's a cute toy
story with him all the time so be sure
to always house I don't know why we
would do that but I was saying
anyway they could play that movie right
now for him hey phones are like
disappear right that's all they do like
like when we had the shows like I went
to go eat some food at that little like
Vietnamese place and this family walked
in and they had two kids were like both
of them under three like just running
all over the place and they just sat him
down and they
their phones men it was just quiet it
was just silent and their kids were just
like shoving noodles under the mouse
like listening to like cartoons and
watching cartoons and I was like oh
that's that's not good and then I was
like what I'm enjoying this quiet
yeah my meal and not hearing you scream
bloody murder at the top of your lungs
as you run around this restaurant so I
guess it's good boy I used to have I
work construction for summer with my dad
I broke concrete and I cleaned up the
site and I bought a little TV with it it
was like the best for me such a couch
potato
when I first to do I had the little
watchman yeah my TV yeah you have to
hold it closed you won't remember this
but you guys will do you guys remember
like in the bus stations they used to
have a TVs quarters in oh yeah to watch
TV in the back in the days I was a bus
oh yeah it was brighter for blood
pressure machine a little boy they had a
television you put quarters in and you
watch movies and we'd be like 15 minutes
like a quarter and then it would just be
like regular TV and get rid of that [ __ ]
I think his people just started like
ripping them off of the arms that seemed
come ahead for those everybody everybody
had was loud it was all loud there was
no headphones I think there was
headphone jacks but who was carrying
headphones at that point nobody and it
was the big one like the 1970s ones but
no I remember I remember being a little
kid I like being like in the station
that was cooler that I remember being I
get really pumped that like I could
watch TV like my own TV that's badass
[Laughter]
were some food we have a Lydia Popovich
by here leather gentleman from the Bay
Area right yeah I raised San Jose
California born and raised San Jose yes
upcoming shows Miami may 31st that's a
Magic City casino I'm headlining the
ultimate Miami comedian competition and
clothing it out was an hour-long set
Schaumburg Illinois June 15 through 17
at the Schomburg improv outside of
Chicago El Paso Texas June 22nd at the
Plaza
in San Antonio Texas June 23rd at the
Tobin Center Orlando Florida June 28th
to July 1st at Orlando improv
check out all Felipe world.com slash
tour because I'm adding new dates all
the time yeah updates coming up yeah I'm
gonna be in San Francisco at the punch
line actually June 6th or June 9 hey
lady
no I'm featuring for jenny zigrino so me
and her will be together and then
tomorrow at the Hollywood improv is
woman crush Wednesday so I will be
hosting tomorrow's night show hater
Tuesday hater Tuesday right yep that's
my Instagram and my Twitter account is
the Twitter yeah what's up full of watch
Orlando we're gonna beat these redneck
family my family this will be the second
time I've met all these other family
member but first I met these people I
met him at my dad's funeral last year so
you might see you go that's not a
footlong that time yeah so we're gonna
yeah I'm gonna meet her brother if the
brother bring his wife and gifts yeah
wife and three daughters and I don't
know if David's coming
my other brother your uncle no he didn't
go have you ever had trouble with
brothers like that girls dated like they
try to Punk you anything would it mean
like you dated a girl and then he just
tries to like assert his dominance in
the area he doesn't meet families oh
right like you haven't met the families
of most of the girls you've been with
right man only one time man this group
over to our house they heard a cube that
I don't know where bro
you know what the hell's going on no but
I remember whose parents a really good
maybe Carrie or no no most of the women
I've dated brought that I have parents
bro oh you don't even [ __ ] mom me my
parents yeah I met both your parents and
all your brothers and sisters except I
think every guy met me what I'm not sure
about you that weird meeting parents no
it's not it's not formal like in the
movies like yo mom nervous or anything I
just came over and they were having
tacos I guess people do something where
they make it like a real formal thing oh
it just seems very antiquated to me it
just kind of run into them when it
happens
like this is this person I know I don't
know what's happening but they're here
right now take a look she doesn't travel
though she's in Ohio and she's people
pretty much that makes a difference
okay remember who I met man I think I
met like one like my high school
girlfriend doesn't first scary one was
the first time yeah it was the first
time and she was like what if he doesn't
like you and I was like it's okay I'm
with you not him no not yet okay what
makes it more nervous like if you know
you've already had sex then you have to
like look her dad in the eye and be like
oh yeah I met my son's mom yeah yeah I
met her dad and everybody brought they
all lived in the house they were all
right they were cool that that was like
he was tripping I didn't have a car
you're telling me that I'm the best
friend is his daughter is twenty dollars
in his pocket and stuff like that but
you don't understand me you know I come
with different generation you know I
don't know where cutting carbon my whole
life is having those blisters
yeah there's that you know man that is
the new generation man you don't need
cars and jobs and it would be
responsible attract women these days you
have to have a pulse that generation
before me they call him a generation
where you gotta [ __ ] look clean all
the time yeah I have a tank top under
all the time with a white t-shirt over
Dan your dresser then you put on your
your boxers white socks and a dress
shoes to go out and tennis shoes to hang
out
increase your pants all the time and
your you get a haircut every week I can
[ __ ] yours mother Oh spies karate do
you always walk clean something soaping
yes I think so pee with the fuse we went
from you know to be like me you know
yeah not here and then that generation
was just wear no pants having a rainbow
hair broke the next generation after
that brought after rainbow hair it's
gonna be just straight up you know we'll
be nude yeah doesn't have tattoos on his
face there's no way he's responsible yes
I mean like he doesn't know what he's
doing with his life his place is clean
what is he doing
you don't even have a beard he doesn't
grown anything this week like you tell
somebody like in 19 when I was a little
kid when I went it was hardcore when I
was out Public Enemy okay you know but
with the cut but you come on the whole
painted face and you but no you were
telling somebody that that's kids rap no
wasn't it was painted to the cloud pass
he was like nines been painting his face
like that whole career better like his
whole career but he's done a pretty
amazing job of like sustaining his
career in like yeah super but he has a
huge following that dude sells records
like he
he really really does and he does it all
himself which is amazing it was pretty
good to be that long and to have like a
generation that just perpetuates the
next generation of people that are gonna
listen to you is I have respect that a
great deal like I know this one guy
who's from the suburbs like chubby white
dude 23 and who's like you know who's my
favorite artist tec-9 he really speaks
to me he speaks to I mean he doesn't
necessarily speak to me personally that
music is not for me but I appreciate and
respect everything that he does and the
fact that it like it speaks to a bunch
of people people like to be inspired see
what I was growing up and if you told
somebody Ozzie speak to you the block
you up bro yeah brother Randy Road
speaks to me bro he says get in a car
drunk and drive me to a tree really bad
like somebody late they labeled a demo
music oh yeah yeah my parents were like
super Christian everything was devil
music man well it's kind of funny when
you think of some of the stuff like even
like stuff like Def Leppard which was
like is pretty soft if you look at it
now but even then they were like that
was in like the section of music that
was like devil music Oh Def Leppard
you're like no that guy has one hand
he's not gonna hurt anybody twisters
yeah all that stuff just because baby
yeah yeah and they still got the girls
twitter yes was so full podcast Libya
would you start off doing stand-up
comedy in San Francisco actually I you
wait a whole year they were done I did I
did we don't know we're talking about
early oh no I found out one time when I
was I'm my headline the punchline in San
Francisco once just once just wartime
and and somebody told me that um so yes
to wit cuz I'm I I wanted to use my own
feature and open her and I fought and I
fought and I fought and I got it right
yeah
so that pissed off a lot of people back
then and but I found out later on was
that the reason they put their own
people there is because they got fools
waiting a whole year brought to get
booked and some people didn't wait
longer than that like I had done comedy
probably for two years just like opened
my King and stuff but and I would go
there every once in a while and then I
was starting to finally feel
okay I'm ready to like really try to
make a show of like let me see if I can
get in at the punchline and that's how
it works like you go every Sunday
there's a Sunday showcase and that's for
local comics and you go and you hang out
and it's probably roughly nine months
and around the nine-month mark then you
should like to introduce yourself to the
Booker and be like hey I've been here
for nine months and they're there
they're watching and they kind of keep
track and see and like their whole
attitude I guess the way that they
describe it to us is that they want to
make sure that you're serious about
doing it because a lot of people come
and then they go up once and then they
come back and then they just think that
they're gonna get up every single time
that they come so it's their way of
pruning out sort of the hobbyist from
the people who are serious they say a
lot of hobby is out there but there is
like honestly in San Francisco like the
scene there is crazy like I left two
years ago and the entire scene now like
I don't know who any of these people are
I'm like I don't know which I guess is
cool that there's not many people
starting off from Florida but ya know
people move me to show up and they're
like oh we like San Francisco's become
this like stop on like the comedy
evolution circuit do you think is very
hard right now for a person to start
doing comedy and it's one I would say 24
25 and really have no money and live
there I think it's impossible the way
they're mostly comedian living it's ever
since no more huh you're gonna be living
with like 9,000 other people and like a
rundown shot in the days of Robin
Williams bro and Larry bubbles brown god
right it's a little more like five
comedian living in one apart there's
actually there is one place that I know
and it's this group of dudes they were
actually on Vice for when they did that
flop house thing but Sue's boys called
Silvan and they live in this huge house
that is in the Richmond District and
it's basically two apartments on top of
each other and they live in filth like
it is disgusting and there's like seven
of them there's people living in closets
there's people living in living rooms
like every single room has been
converted but that's how they make it
happen but it's also gross like I don't
know how they have sex with girls and
bring women home but they do but that's
the only place I know that is like that
everywhere else is just like so
expensive I saw the documentary but
they're so like um like I'll just take a
room like this and they'll put
kompong beds like 1 2 3 and they'll set
it up in here like I actually like like
a prison module yeah and and you you
back or you let yuddhistir cubicle
there's no door I get the respect or the
other lock but you living like in a
prison you know here in LA of comics
that live in places that are like
bedrooms that are split by curtains
those are pleased enough like like a
summer camp doors right I have a door
Alva door tomorrow I'm talking about a
curtain like see ya so wait how do you
yeah man I don't know I always think
about that cuz like I started comedy
later in life so I never went through
the like struggling to feed myself thing
yeah I was like had my life kind of
together and there was like all right
let me do comedy now but in San
Francisco is not a good place to be a
young person right now and struggling
with anything because it's just
egregiously I'm gonna stop telling
people to do their hotel you know what
bro started Houston it happening
straight up straight up honestly there's
like around 4 legit comedy clubs and at
least 10 rooms and at least eighty one
night or that pop up every month and so
much work keep working you develop off
you could develop a tight 30 and then
test it out of here not late for a while
yeah absolutely I mean that's one thing
I will say about service Co it's like if
you like when I was there and everyone
that I know that came out of San
Francisco we all got a lot of time like
once you get through the gauntlet like
once you start proving yourself as funny
like that year thing kind of diminishes
a little bit like I got my audition as a
host and hosted for like less than a
year before I moved into feature and it
was a quick jump for me and that's
because I just was like consistently
funny and I was able to leave there with
like a good chunk of time because there
was so much time and there was so many
different rooms but San Francisco
audiences are all so different I think
going somewhere like Houston is very
very smart because you have a much more
diverse audiences there San Francisco is
a bunch of what I like to call like
people with NPR itis yeah who are just
like very can
serve ative but their liberal so their
conservative yeah they just don't know
what to laugh at anymore and they want
permission to laugh at something it's
it's gonna be a little disturbing like
they're just not as free as they once
were liberals have gone I party last
year but I can see that the Liberals
these days are the biggest form of
censorship the biggest group yeah all
questions constantly about everything it
makes it hard to be a comic abilities
have fun for 12 minutes here without you
questioning like my moral standards like
that's what we're saying here you have
fun you need to do better you need to go
further
he had no message to that message abroad
[Laughter]
to look for hope just be a funny guy
what happened to that guy do you wanna
make him laugh yeah I know but you never
quit nobody meeting with question back
in the days like Bob Hope
there was his Jews right that people
died in World War two you were there
telling jokes
Carter so be sure to sit down Don
Rickles and talk to him about you know
all the words he was using the judging
of people you're kidding me you know not
saying everything that you said was
great either but it's the same time it's
like put it in the context artists part
comedy hasn't escaped though the
comedian now from that I you know he
pulls it up or of his two daughters they
wanna miss graduating high school going
to college one of them is gonna graduate
high school in a year and a half or two
years he said these are my daughters
he goes man they're um they know
everything and they protest everything
there's social social warriors right
here they're so little but they already
offended by everything it's like see
people don't give a chance for others to
get offended first yeah get offended on
their behalf yeah yeah oh it's a lot of
good
[Laughter]
what kind of drama anything you have you
dealt with in them fellas is cool you
know what there's always drama and all
you just starting it to see it much
exactly I mean I saw drama but I just
wasn't a party too much is it because I
was exactly I did yeah that was and
honestly the drama was because of that
people were like oh she's stuck-up oh
she thinks she's too good oh Beauvoir
she's unapproachable oh she's cold I had
a comedian that kept on just like trying
to be overly like aggressively friendly
like really trying to push the
friendship thing and I'm not a big
person who likes to have anything forced
like they're gonna click oh that's cool
and that doesn't mean that I don't
respect you and then I want you to do
your work but like just because we're
both comedians doesn't mean we need to
be like holding hands and [ __ ] text
messaging everyday in [ __ ] like I don't
know and so this person basically pushed
me into a corner and then just started
sort of talking [ __ ] about me a little
bit to other comics like you know I
don't know I asked you do you want to be
comedy buddies
[Laughter]
the woods yeah but yeah so I had to like
and I'm not the kind of person that like
here you're saying some [ __ ] I'm gonna
say some [ __ ] yeah so I had to be like
listen I just don't like you as a person
I just don't like you I don't artists
turned down a friend and a woman must be
harder than a woman cuz if you're a dude
you just like all that food it was I it
was just I just was very bothered by it
because my whole thing was like I just
want to I just want to write my jokes I
want to do my time I want to do my jokes
and I want to leave I know this is I'm
not here for this and I'm here for that
but there's all kinds of course there's
always people you know oh you stole this
from me oh you didn't write with me or
oh you didn't do this with me like drama
and comedy is universal the same issues
always show up everywhere it's
ridiculous I know like um sometimes like
like there's people who like just like I
started off just doing coffeehouse
mm-hmm but at the coffee house I'm a
Latino convenience there and don't
Latino comedian turned me on to other
Latino rooms ma'am there were no J's
many Latino rooms but I don't think they
will they're not really called Latino
rules you'd happen to be this yeah you
know their restaurant a Tuesday they
told me yeah makeup done it'll be a
comedy show a Black Angus in in the
[ __ ] Ambra and I said no wait a
minute brought a restaurant yeah but the
[ __ ] kick everybody out the comedy
broke I had to that performing in weird
places like it was tough but it was over
[ __ ] Birds yeah you take the belt
Bobby's hard it was Bobby yeah it was my
favorite thing to do is I won't be on
stage and there's like two carbons
sitting over there trying to pick up but
it was two girls and then they're like
buying a table of five and everybody's
standing I would say there was there was
less than fifty people bro
you could hear the silverware clinking
against each other the beaches here
already late
that was the one thing in San Francisco
that we didn't have is the scenes groups
um no there's a bunch of rooms but it's
not divided by race it's just like Oh
everybody yeah like there's no like
there's not a black room in a Latino
room and I'm white room the only real
difference is people who are like sort
of super ulti comedy that are basically
like doing more improv or weird sketch
[ __ ] and they are doing straight up
stand up and that was kind of the device
Bobby
yes exactly pretty much and I'm like
wondering like how come they're laughing
at you because you didn't do anything
you just been out for 12 I must and I
walked into um simply walked into an out
room and I think it was a little cotton
but I'm doing a raffle it was they're
closing it out and then um no she was
gonna go up but they had a bunch of
people before her he happened to be in
there he was telling me that story broke
worse it was literally in the airport I
was telling with him with Chris Spencer
hmm and I mean he believed it man he's
funny all right
I don't know well you say it's funny I
never story goes up if see but you gonna
go up man ever seen nobody else in here
[Laughter]
but when I started like I would go to
like wow I was going to the cop this
combination that place called the
natural purge and it was a bunch of
different comedians man homeless
comedians weird comedians I'm dual
comedians ya can be interested weird
called outfits
rock and roll comedians bro or just dumb
weird of a girl and I saw a lot of lumps
of boat in this rating so at all right
hos man older do that that um
no Jerry can
really the homeless comics used to scare
me all the time I get it like they let
everybody perform there it's been five
dollars yeah
which is kinda great we had a place that
was like that services was called the
brainwash which was a cafe and a
laundromat so one half it was a good
idea like you could it was open till
10:00 you could wash clothes in the back
and then the front was a cafe and a
little coffee shop and then they had an
open mic there so it was like pretty
much open mics like every it was like
Wednesday and Thursday and everybody
would come including the homeless people
the crazy crackheads like there was just
this that was a place where everyone
went and you'd go up when you do to time
but you didn't have to even buy anything
you just had to be there and sign up and
then you would get your time because
they would start at 6:00 and end at like
midnight so you'd sit there forever and
ever and ever and ever and wait but then
yeah you'd get to see crazy people do
crazy stuff but then people show up like
Robin Williams came one time and just
kind of came into the open mic there and
you were like oh okay maybe this is
worthwhile and then everyone who had
like left San Francisco would come back
and do that room too but that was a cool
room but it doesn't exist it was like a
factory open mic that's the same thing
it used to be fewer oh so I will do as a
natural fudge and like I'm not the only
Latino comedian for a while they're too
afraid only Freddy Soto yeah but now and
then I would go to this place called
Waldo's comedy station it was like
that's a good and the Hollywood hotel on
Highland they have comedy there every
Saturday they still you come I got to do
a lady there and then she liked me
because I would always kill with my five
minutes and then she want you to host
we're gonna pay you how much 60 bucks
when I met Carla the Oscar there I
remember they paid him $100 and the
headliner and then um I met Jamie Foxx
there one time like he was there was
another comedian but he would not
performing you just hanging out yeah
it's tough talking alright but um and
then from there I mean the reason I went
to Latino room because I meant Latinos
who told me if you go there they'll give
you money so so okay
siren song for the only paid man
at least and I got to and I got to hang
around with my comedian that at the time
we're already established as like Willie
Barcena and Rudy Marino Luke Torres
Gilbert Esquivel Larry Omaha
Dante guards I was another guy I know he
passed away big dollop Wow he was like
the 80s Latino comedian mix for the 90s
comedians you know so I got to the hills
louder a lot of spots and then one day
the natural fudge the that white lady
that owned the coffee house told me that
they were they were doing them Latino -
the comedy at the Laugh Factory but
didn't get in there I didn't know
anybody it wasn't - I met Johnny Sanchez
and he gave me the phone number and I
call the Laugh Factory
hmm that's what I go in there nothing
all night yeah it's a blessing and a
curse the theme nights yeah I think back
then yeah they needed like a foot in the
door different groups of you know
different ethnicities who weren't
getting booked it came out of a need you
know in Paul Rodriguez was pushing for
it at the Laugh Factory
as a way to bring up these younger
Latino comics but I think now they need
to go away that's my opinion because
they it hurt for one those guys get the
nights that are the undesirable night
club Monday Monday Tuesday Wednesday you
know that's the black and Latino Sundays
at the Laugh Factory
I mean they're good because they bring
in like this core audience and there's
this camaraderie and whatever the
supposed to be yeah but it's also
negative because you try to go to the
Laugh Factory to get a Friday spot and
you can't get a Friday spot because they
see you as the guy who fits into Latino
night you know what I mean yeah are you
for your black so you fit into the urban
night or chocolate Sunday night or trip
it on Tuesdays or whatever well bed of
Mondays yep not told Wednesday you know
it was helpful in the past but I think
it's worn out it's it's neat you know
it's necessity and now I think all rooms
should just know nobody was there mixed
anyway I mean
those Booker's will the people running
those rooms will book other people a lot
of Latino comedian our daily life stayin
in the East Side that's true too
there's so many like when I was doing
stand-up comedy while in like before
like almost a 2006 before that's common
standing I have paid gigs lined up all
week without ever touching Hollywood
yeah like like I had a Latino night
Elementor was making what 235 but they
don't take off then I run to us go to
another room okay $50 there and then on
Tuesday or Coral Castle Athena they'll
give you 75 the IRS is listening 75 and
a Thursday a hundred then Saturday
another 75 Friday pretty much no gigs on
Friday there were nothing to even it was
hardly a Latino to go to a comedy show
on Friday yeah
so nothing brother let's go out of town
and Fresno yeah I remember Joe dia
that's right [ __ ]
he cancelled a gig on New Year's Eve man
for Fresno with a hotel to over $300 he
told me I didn't have to get over 100
but I kept at 200 and I was happy man
and I drove over there New Year's Eve
show headline I ate I can't wait I was
sober it's perfect a sober room it has
to have fun I thought to remember times
when I was sober now but I guess I
didn't have time well then smoke weed or
let him drink I was too happy possible I
still consider you sober yeah complete
180 since I met you when you like Lisa
Lisa I used to work on the truck the
chocolate sundae the laugh at we're
talking about drama and it was Tamara
she thought drama firsthand is what's
giving her shows up it's over oh yeah
everybody gets bombed
well the whole social more than that you
know community oh yeah they sit in there
but there's you know Corey Holcomb Scott
and in fights about jokes scruncho has
been on stage like there's drama
in all these groups and you know and
like I'm talking about a lot of white
comics they just they're a little more
silent about it I can either be having
drama because they move in silent don't
sabotage my comedian would sabotage
another white comedian in the morning
mm-hmm like he'll cut up the cabinet oh
you're gonna line up okay scratch him
please yeah I'm not gonna come if that
guy's going on yeah passive-aggressive
sorry but what if they cook is there you
can't Chris D'Elia there yeah - or like
Daniel - or like you know I mean if
every spirit is there you can have D
networks or whatever example bro
remember what their Johnny statues do
they want to do they want to go up on a
Latino after a Latino he didn't want to
be right next to the other Latinos yeah
because the whole line up with white
right me I don't care man just cope into
your time to be funny yeah just go and
have a good time like like um there's a
lot of beef in the Latino community no
community especially I was the only Ally
in Hollywood here in the area it's
because I'm we still think there's only
room for one of the problems come you
know once Latino comedians and black
comedians stop thinking that we're there
they've been the rule for everybody but
you know what's at stake time it's gonna
happen overnight
Eli when we had called Oscar he's gonna
take time bro and he can happen but you
know what there's progress because they
turned down ten Latino pilot last year
well the last ten five okay
and also man it must be even harder like
just say was the comedy show and there's
only one woman and they late most common
show up review probably good I don't
give a [ __ ] you go to any line up right
now if you look it up there's gonna be
one walk maybe two and that's it so that
means let me see maybe a harder man for
four went for women to be fighting each
other so you get moving silence - you
know what I think there's my support
there's a lot more support in female
community it's pretty cool actually like
for the most part people have realized
that we're not doing each other any
favors by pushing each other apart and
that the more consistently funny we are
and the more consistent that we show up
and that we're all there and everyone
goes to your time and shows up and it's
great it's undeniable and it's also
there's a lot of women that are coming
together to create channels to do stuff
who cares what everybody else is doing
and I kind of feel that same way about
like all the individual races like yes
there's only certain amount of spots but
there's an are those are you waiting for
someone to give you a spot or are you
going to create everything you can't be
waiting for somebody to give you
something something might hand can be
fighting and [ __ ] the believe general
job man you know you should do
stop yelling about it a woman right five
new jokes I know five jokes that are so
personal fighting with a comedian with a
DVD in your head and hitting it with it
yeah it just does it's a waste of time
it's a super big waste of time but I
don't know for me I think being I mean I
wish that there was more women on bills
but I don't mind being the only woman on
the bill sometimes because goo I'm funny
as [ __ ] and it works out yeah and then
I'm Latino too so I scoop up a lot of
work because I'm like they're like two
for one she's all Agito answers a lady's
been beneficial to me since I've been in
town I haven't suffered as much as some
other people have right now the the
women we need to be sorry for is the
white women the white women are having a
hard time
so you got a good network of people like
you and Marcela and like that group yeah
and that you guys have kind of formed in
LA stronger I think than any group of
women who've been there before because
maybe the guys can operate as
individuals and not need another guy
there like as a mentor buddy or whatever
you know your lone wolf out there but a
lot of women you can't move like that
you know you hear stories from Felicia
from back in the 80s and that sort of
thing in that whole scene and like
people who are following her home and
you gotta have that welcome either tell
you about their hiring one female every
week I better call them network of
people and you know Marcela like she's
starting to help you know women with
their submissions like the things that
you submit and like mistakes not to make
like she's doing it yeah the goodness of
her heart like she wants these women to
get better she wants to be like a
workshop yeah and like you know those
are the sort of things that you guys
need to be doing in there awesome to see
it happening you know just think are
murder I mean there's a bunch of
different boards on Facebook that like
women are always interacting with and
like asking each other questions asking
for support and like oh do you know how
to write a treatment oh you're done how
do I record voiceovers how do I do this
there's always almost Constitution super
cool I belong to loco which is the
ladies of comedy loca but it's um it's
all like it's all behind the scenes
women yep no talent Oh group so it's all
agents managers Booker's publicists all
those sorts of things so they're really
helpful and we passed comics names
around here and there yeah cool no you
gotta ask your friends man you got to
always like lean on your friends my cell
has been huge help to me since I've got
here honestly she is really me comments
made it better no it's not that's
disabled was so boo what's up bro here
look like taxi driver don't always been
a problem with Latino community you know
because I remember I when I first
started comedy I won't speak to like
only common it ever
meaning forever like big Dunlap Larry
Omaha and they will tell me that no bro
the only given like he was tell me that
was that it was first daily or nods of
course yeah
then many many years came back and then
they had chicken a man and then another
20 years came back and then they had um
Paul Rodriguez yeah okay Pablo you know
20 years came along and they had George
Lopez there another 20 cristela yeah
there another 10 years like a canceled
they canceled five pilots so progress
broke and because there's more
television now yes and you know what you
don't need a network to have your ozone
you have a camera you can put a YouTube
be consistent build an audience yeah
don't forget a lot of these things that
are on you know as web series or like
look at ISA Ray Show insecure on HBO
that started as a web series it started
as a blog before that and it blew into
this show and now she's creating things
and she's building other shows and
movies and things for other actors and
writers so it can happen as long as it's
good it was a joke oh it's a process you
gotta like turn on the camera and do it
like me and Nick we did a web series and
we had to just like do it we didn't
write it out I think we're just like we
get first episode down and then we get
the rest done
we got like 12 episodes out of it you
acting you know what I haven't I haven't
done a lot of acting I'm a little
intimidated I'm not gonna lie it's kind
of like I don't know it's intimidating I
don't know why it's something I need to
get over which is weird because like I'm
not intimidated or scared on stage at
all with like a billion faces looking at
me but then one camera by myself is
intimidating so it's something I'm
trying to learn it myself into but I
think all Deborah Lemon mmm lemon
Studios right there are sober like I've
been going there for a year consistently
for Betty Ann do you feel like it like
it was like before you started seeing
her like were you comfortable like
acting or did you feel like [ __ ] suck
I just become hyper aware I feel like I
become hyper aware of everything my face
is doing as soon as a camera is putting
on me and then I start over correcting
and I'm like oh
Oh once again I said I'm good just dish
apart is bad yeah yeah once he what's up
in a snap man yeah I got the cameraman
telling me where to stand
privately look good plus they want their
peeled a shot to air right they want to
have like what they're creating yeah go
in the right direction
no I think it's just something I have to
get more comfortably need to like start
wrapping my could look into like its
call it an Alexander and Alexander is
usually a former stage stage actors but
in Alexander Alexander Technique is like
to look at your body and can't be aware
of where your body is positioned where
how your face is positioned as you're
performing I mean so you don't have that
what am i doing my I there oh I'm
staring at myself I'm not looking at the
camera and then I start talking I'm like
I'm like a two-year-old child yeah stuff
like that like I think it's an Alexander
who could help with something
yeah but like I mean I act and well out
you know what I mean like we all we're
all comics it's like of course if I'm
like in like something with something I
can like improvise like figure some
stuff out and I can remember stuff it's
just a matter of like how do I identify
school in college that helped acting in
high school in college yeah I was in
Greece no paper nerdy guy that's all a
nerdy guy just like a side character
with dog it was just it was a trash can
[Laughter]
was so full so man we had a great week
at the Irvine improv Austria will
perform
yeah dad it was [ __ ] fine six shows
dope you and almost seven the other one
was like George Perez donor Rob Marty
Moreno who de Moreno marcin reso
that's it huh
Lidia Popovich Johnny rocket myself you
said George yeah yeah lajjo pulls out
some of the shows they ran out of beers
they ran out of Sunday they were out
when they started the shift yeah
replaced it they were out of blue moon
they were out of Corona they were out of
Modelo they were not Saturday night late
crowd yeah
but in a good way though like I mean I'm
not mad at people are drunken having a
good time and they're not like wiling
out you know I mean really mad a beer
how'd that work they didn't run out of
beer completely they ran out of the good
beers yeah yeah people are sad but in
Bud Light and stuff and you know all
that I'm so late this is am still a it's
not really good you have to have brown
ale favorite yeah red or the little
blues all right yeah no that was my
favorite actually for my high school
graduation I got a keg of that beer and
bought it and put it in my backyard and
like hid it I don't even actually don't
even hit I think I convinced my mom that
was gonna be okay yeah I cried just was
like I'm just it's gonna be fine like no
one's gonna drive I could have told my
mom back then that we could have beer
because you really thought that they
still had the three the three to law or
whatever it was like you get near beer
remember near beer uh-huh in the back to
the day before I was a kid oh dude my
mom's generation you could get like
three percent or five up to my person
like that alcohol without being without
being 21 so if you were eight and my
mom's thought that she was like well
can't you just get near beer or and she
didn't care if I drink I just didn't
really want to what a sub fool man so
they sold out shows yeah we had the
rapper's in the hotel room they were
pissed off the whole week man one of
them tried to take a shower
this buddy's got moxie I came into the
bathroom the rescue no fearsome I got a
dirty way honestly like picturing a
bunny trapped in a toilet like that's
gonna stick with me for a minute that's
a very very funny visual he couldn't get
out he was and then I got him out and
wrap them in a towel of course he didn't
like that either kind of dry off his
feet they don't like being wet like
they'll have a heart attack
but he wasn't show slippers who got wet
she would have had a heart attack she
will let the rabbit in here with eggs
I learned that Robbins can't throw up I
didn't know that either that was a
fascinating fact when I'm done speaking
about rabbits no idea there'll be a test
next week was so full right now man a
lot a lot of drama without it we can
humble yeah man it was insane
how did you find out I found out through
facebook Messenger then I called him all
big news is disseminated these days very
good on Facebook it didn't and it said
post from Nick Nick Guerra yeah I know
that Willie Barcena just punched me what
yeah Willie Barcena nah bro nah bro it
was my face bro you know was a little
Gore just go yes I don't what Nick
posted we don't we don't know the
details we weren't there
it's a Ledge list of what were they
happen at a restaurant at the club or
they were forward together is that a
restaurant is that a restaurant in the
Red Roof Inn no but it's a little yeah
oh my god that is that Pressman
Kavya is good as menudo bro and let me
tell my I never eat in there but Willy
will brag about it Willie Barcena okay
now bro right there bro they don't [ __ ]
around bro they give you [ __ ] menudo
with was all it was toast yeah I don't
even know what tortillas or other
regions or chairs at all but if I'm
phool like toast well [ __ ] that [ __ ] no
idea what happened bro the deal is the O
ride at the police show up they stopped
the fight police showed up super late
they didn't stop the fight rappin was
just one punch right what did he do more
o2 on a neck hold kind of like he was
accused of stealing a joke was accused
of stealing a joke yeah wait so he had a
watch or something
can I put side-by-side videos look at 19
and 53 seconds who do the homework and
get back to me and I'm gonna I'm gonna
come find you in a random town and then
we're gonna talk about yeah and this was
at the ice house a while ago yeah I
don't like a random show he was even
booked on the show he saw Nichols booked
on the show and I guess and he has to
dude for a spine he got a spot but he
was like hey here's my DVD sure sure
look at it and a nickel thing now Willie
I didn't do it you know I didn't still
and with the plane of the video just
show you know handing him
of handing a reference material so like
he didn't he didn't he didn't accept the
accusation it was just like not get away
from me and walked away so months later
they meet at the Village Inn and no
password this weekend didn't meet he
shows up with reference material well he
shows up no no he brought the audience I
was just over here but he brought the
audience that was so right from the show
I brought it as a feature when Willy add
that he showed up here well then he was
in El Paso - well it's in a run and I
think Corpus Christi and then he passed
through to go to Vegas is good enough
bro to make a 70 mile [ __ ] detour
brother so when he gets there Willy
walks up to the guy featuring for Nick
and doesn't pay any mind to Nick and
just says hey what's a manic I don't
remember the guys name
I just know April you're big yeah heard
a lot about you you're a good comic I
really like you and they were 38 so they
don't have like he intentionally doesn't
like pay any attention Nick so Nick
Knowles Willy's opener and he does that
same thing he just walks up to hey
you're a good comic blah blah mocking
you you can't be 4 foot 11 bro machina
guy I don't know about that each other
you can't like you can be mocking me bru
either bro yeah if I'm trying to be cool
but like it was one of the things that
he did like he didn't pay attention
hamster is like fine I'm gonna pay
attention to me I make you pay attention
to me and then like he got over him like
he
back to sit down at his booth and then
Willie went over I was just like you
mocking me and then Nick was like yeah I
am mocking you and then that's when you
got hit twice and all right then they
sure that should've just matter you
mocked him the guy's violent you
shouldn't have provoked you me there
have been stories yeah there's a sign
that's come I don't mess with him
anytime like people always like I got
comics that I knew they were hanging
around with him I was like nah he was in
the right I wouldn't provoke the bear
those are the kind of words I'm saying
if you've been at least ten fights at
that height right you're scrapping
you're looking forward to thank you yeah
you guys can be a badass with a suit bro
and provoke some at that but still
especially with Willie Barcena who so
would hit him yeah well let him twice
and he tried to like choke him Dale and
then the manager pulled him off and like
the features pulled him off and then he
took off like they just took off
allegedly allegedly allegedly that
happened with witnesses but with
witnesses and then allegedly took off
like down where Louie's out there just
stoking up the wheel wow you know what
man I feel bad more for the guy that
opening for Willie a red equated
reignite the whole fight with him he's
gotta get props yeah bro he was wrong
he's gotta get props though it I think I
give you props bro for holding me back
problems it's got a good grip wow I
wasn't even thinking that happened that
way I just made it up there was a little
mocking there well I felt like it would
have been like a in indirect mocking
yeah but like when I found it was direct
Asik Oh him props for standing up but at
the same time it's not something I would
do in that heavy borrows but you know
what sometimes get you but you know well
you took the pose like a soldier you
know first one's always the hardest it's
either that or he shows up everywhere
and just Punk's you every time yeah yeah
but yeah but if I want to see Willie
Barcena hit the ugly comedy club in Las
Vegas oh we came out check him out don't
tell them to your friends though do not
repeat those jokes I guess you want to
hand-delivered the comedian that were
there were the people that were carven
team we're like him during that
comedians huh that's the thing though
there are some comedians on there of
course but there are a lot of fans and
when fancy that stuff they don't know
what's going context yeah remember you
and Jeff cursed you and the devil got
you know when you punked him after Last
Comic Standing and kicked him off the
stage and grabbed the mic and all that
stuff that whole thing happened in front
of fans yeah who we're in the middle of
watching a comedy show and he walks in
and comes on the stage and whatever
upsets it all we all and the comics all
were like the fans were just like what's
going on like they had no clue who are
these people are they fighting but you
know fans when you do that when you have
fans who are just people who saw you on
TV they don't know what's going on and
they don't want to be part of it they
don't want to see it either you know
Mira Rizal talked about that for weeks
yeah really like did you see remember
when he jumped on the stool holy [ __ ] we
jumped on the stool
didn't you think for something I got on
the stage took the mic Oh at the Sunday
yeah and then they kicked Jeff Jeff was
like talking [ __ ] and then he left they
kicked him out and didn't let him back
in will be the birth wife oh yeah thanks
next next month I'm gonna be at this at
the San Mateo Jenga will be important go
a chunga Changa
and at the end of the month at the last
week gonna be Rock Cafe you know Vegas I
think you're gonna be with was some fool
I'll be at the before yeah a little
while well shut it up again hater
Tuesday why is it hater Tuesday always
wondering so the the the short and long
of is this I used to be a very negative
person
I'm still pretty negative but it used to
be a little bit out of control and my
friends told me that they didn't think
that I could make a new year's
resolution to not say negative [ __ ] like
all the time so I was like yeah I can
what are you talking about I lasted
about two months and was just ready to
explode so what I started doing is a
joke as I was like man just give me like
one day a week I just need like like
even people are on diets have a cheat
day like I need a cheat day Tuesday's
gonna be my cheat day hilarious so what
I would do is the whole week when we
were hanging out like you know when you
talk [ __ ] to your friends you say stuff
they just said I made too much fun of
them like they couldn't take it so I
would just start taking notes of all the
little petty [ __ ] that happened that I
would have said in real life and I took
notes about it I yeah I sent them you
know and I was like last Thursday we
were at dinner you said this Beauvoir
comment so I basically would just send
them the notes of like all of my hating
notes and it became hater Tuesday and it
turning into a LiveJournal and then that
LiveJournal turned into a blog and then
I had a website that's actually what
kicked off comedy is it was just me
hating on my friends and then hating on
all the things that I saw around me and
then I just stuck with it because I
liked it or Tuesday but I don't opt out
the website anymore because now I do
stand-up and it's just too much work
[Laughter]
what silence and a raised eyebrow he's
thinking why I rock it showed up with
wearing all of his clothes we did you
show him when you were wearing his
jacket yeah dude I saw Alfa Robles a
little clip you did you particular three
right yeah I did
that was to face bro when he when he
posed on Instagram you know when he was
gay bro huh he looks like all right for
their bra that party look he's back 300
pounds oh that neg dog look like dick
party that neck was a [ __ ] guest
Barbara that name South merch bro
on the side now fool you like a
salamander bro baby broad the order it
bro he lost some weight a few years ago
and gave me some clothes he's asking for
the back now he was a 42s bad dog he's
happy boy the last comic standing on the
game regulators toward my team is guard
he G Reilly we don't know but he's gone
the guys had even seen him on Instagram
he's he's living the OSI now I never got
to see him
Alfred who moved out of East LA Oh see
now you're still over there he's over
there talking [ __ ] about the burrito how
they ain't that good back home in East
LA my mom used to make it these white
rice scat who secure the calories God
he's always gone cats take care them
sound they're not magic I mean they are
but they're you know they can't like
open up bags like say two to three days
later self water yeah but they need that
attention that's it
really yeah I think he just got it for
the Instagram post you have a fancy
captain that definitely has attention to
shops yeah for sure new top I need
someone to hang out I thought what a
diva hiding over a cool under his chin
face whatever you're saying he don't
believe you Harley I'm trying to catch
his glasses well some of the [ __ ]
sound guy bro everybody sound guy too
professional bro especially like we're
not we're not the [ __ ] taj mahai
president Donald Trump is not speaking
about here speak throw it off saliva
like a gotta go show you don't mean I
don't need you to write down notes
should I show up with a [ __ ] $20 $25
moleskin write down everybody's like
who's gonna look at this [ __ ] mouse
key later oh look he wrote down for care
now gyro kidney it's a sound Journal
there was a lot of notes and a lot of
questions I've never interacted that
much with the sound guy before I
appreciate his attention to detail but
it was a lot
action much I've been lucky to have a
guy just be like the lights go up on
stage just a mind when the audience
there but you couldn't do them there's
no one there to see your ass you want to
chat or not keep missing a whole [ __ ]
house like a whole it's a production
entertainment he takes away the fun he
comes out he did the river they do
comedy 20 years ago Dean direct he was
not a Hellraiser though or del razor
mustachio a little one it wasn't as big
it wasn't a weird - yeah he had a
mustache beard this guy had face tattoos
he did have a mustache I'm like
visualize a little I think he had a
little mustachio
he came in I hear the sheriff sound town
you know I don't like either tune a
sound guy I saw the photographer he's
showing you other photo he took at that
concert or show you oh my god I'm gonna
sound guy I don't know what sure we were
but he was like standing next to me when
I was born check check and he had a key
chain was every [ __ ] backstage pass
he ever worked and he had to show me
[Laughter]
nitrene renegade but joe leave i
Romanian bro
partly suck
half of oats
[Laughter]
all right everybody um we're gonna go
now and we're going to thank our guests
Lydia Popovich our co-host with no most
without the most our new rookie right
here virgin is a reclaimed version
please put down that hole size six
sorry her drug can't I was go back to
the airport
oh thank you very much everybody thank
you for the bag thank you